legend has it that oscar-winning
screenwriter
was Billy Wilder was told by Samuel
Goldwyn you have all the seams just go
home and word it in people think that
what writers do is easy and the better
the writer the easier it looks
screenwriters who take on adaptations
must also stay true to the original
authors vision as they impart their own
creativity in crafting a story for the
big screen here are the nominees for
adapted screenplay those who work so
hard to make it look so easy
Alexander Payne and nat faxon and jim
rash for the descendants based on the
novel by Kaui Hart Hemmings John Logan
for Hugo based on the book entitled The
Invention of Hugo Cabrera
by Brian Selznick George Clooney and
grant Heslov and beau Willimon for the
Ides of March
facing the play Farragut North by beau
William Moneyball screenplay by Steven
Zaillian and Aaron Sorkin story by Stan
Shubin
based on the book by Michael Lewis
Bridget O'Connor and Peter strong for
Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy based on the
novel by John McElroy
and the Oscar goes to Alexander Payne
Nat Faxon Jim rash The Descendants
this is the first Academy Award a
nomination for nat faxon and jim rash
who are former members of The
Groundlings Alexander Payne takes home
his second Oscar
this is Jim and this is NAT I'm
Alexander we bow to our fellow nominees
I'll stop the counter thank you rebound
to our fellow nominees we want to thank
Fox Searchlight producer Jim Burke for
all their good works we share this with
George Clooney and the rest of the cast
for interpreting our screenplays so
generously and we also share it in
particularly with in particular with
Kaui Hart Hemmings our beautiful
Hawaiian flower for her novel and on a
brief personal note if I may my mother
is here with me from Omaha and holding
applause and after watching the show a
few years ago she made me promise that
if I ever won another Oscar I had to
dedicate it to her just like Javier
Bardem did with his mother so mom this
one's for you
Saka papouli and thanks for letting me
skip nursery school so we could go to
the movies thanks a lot